estaban diez tiburones en un arrecife
los tenemos por aquí uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete ocho nueve diez
tal como nos dijeron pero dos de esos
tiburones se alejaron nadando entonces
cuántos tiburones se quedaron pues vamos
a pensar en esto tenemos diez tiburones
diez tiburones de los cuales dos se
alejaron nadando dos se alejaron y
queremos saber cuántos tiburones se
quedaron entonces tenemos que pensar en
cuánto es 10 menos 2 y para eso pues
podemos observar este dibujo de aquí
arriba tenemos aquí a los 10 tiburones
y los tiburones se alejaron nadando
entonces estos dos tiburones se fueron y
en el arrecife se quedaron 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
y 8 entonces 10
- 2 es igual a 88 10 tiburones quitando
los dos tiburones que se alejaron
nadando restando estos dos tiburones nos
quedan ocho tiburones